if there's one thing all super mario
games have in common it's the massive
amounts of creative platforming and
funny characters that make for the truly
unforgettable adventures that many of us
hold near and dear to our hearts
if there are two things they have in
common it's the many features that were
going to be in the games but got cut
from the final game before release
no joke there are literally so many
hidden items
areas animations and even complete game
function to be found in the game's files
that the hardest part of writing this
script was actually just choosing the
few most
interesting features to talk about you
know so this video doesn't end up being
2 hours long
and since we had the big data leak
recently from super mario 64 which i'm
sure
many of you have heard about i'm
actually not going to cover 64 in this
video
but rest assured i have delved through
the pages and pages of hidden and cut
content from super mario sunshine and
super mario galaxy
so that i could bring this freshly baked
cake of interesting information to your
youtube watch page for your viewing
pleasure
and what's more is this video was so big
that i have been gracefully joined by a
fabulous fellow youtuber to help bring
it to life
please welcome the one and only nintendo
black crisis from the channel nintendo
black
crisis well since we have two games to
cover in this one let's start off with
the newer one
super mario galaxy as many of you will
recall the game takes the classic super
mario platforming experience and throws
it
to infinity and beyond
you spend a lot of the time running
around different worlds i mean
galaxies that each have a bunch of
different little planets for mario to
run around on
and i mean a bunch but speaking of
planets
the game was actually supposed to
feature a lot more some of which
are pretty interesting we've got cut
planets like the star planet which is
just a giant power star from mario 64.
bathtub planet which is a giant bathtub
home planet which was actually used for
some demo pictures before the game's
release
and a planet shaped like a giant disc
with its own clouds and sun
but of all the removed planets the most
interesting one is definitely the
starman fort planet
which was actually fully developed and
caused the development team a bit of
heartache when it was scrapped
according to this concept art starman
fort was actually the first planet
designed for the game and
even helped to solidify the super mario
game as super mario galaxy
we can't know for sure why this was
scrapped ultimately
maybe it was because it didn't fit with
the story somehow but either way it's
very interesting that the first planet
that was fully designed and developed
and that helped give life to the entire
game is something nobody will ever get
to experience by normal means
and that's kind of depressing well how
about we look at some removed models and
animations to lighten things up
as is commonly found in the game files
of games that were developed by teams
who develop
multiple games there are actually models
embedded in galaxy from the team's
previous projects like this boat from
super mario sunshine or some
enemies from donkey kong jungle beat no
joke
although these models were most likely
never actually intended to be in the
game and were probably
added in just for some testing early on
in development but
some enemy models definitely were like
these bullies from mario 64 that were
fully modeled and textured and even
animated there's also this strange
little enemy called a canopy which is a
play on toad's japanese name
kenopio and you can see why it's got
this strange
drawn on looking face and apparently was
animated to hop around and harm mario if
he touched it
and to be honest with you i'm not sure
whether to be terrified of the thing or
to find it
strangely adorable but speaking of
animations mario himself
actually has an entire set of animations
cut from the game
and wouldn't you know it they're all
related to playing tennis
yeah tennis in space we've got stuff
like running with a tennis racket
hitting with a tennis racket even
waiting
with a tennis racket i have no idea
where or how this would have been
implemented into the game but my guess
is this idea was scrapped to make way
for the standalone tennis title
mario tennis aces which is
understandable since they did do a whole
lot with that concept and it was
probably way too big to fit into a super
mario title
the last bit of cut models i'll cover
for galaxy would be these interesting
looking vehicles
one that resembles large legs called the
two leg walker
and the other that resembles a tiny
two-wheeled car called the two-wheel
tank
both vehicles were apparently scrapped
even before receiving textures but i'd
imagine that they would change the way
some of the terrain or even enemies felt
let's move on to super mario sunshine
which has even more cut content than
galaxy did
since the release of super mario 3d
all-stars no doubt
many of you have heard the really choppy
voice editing that happens when mario
picks up flood for the first time
i mean even though it's understandable
since it would have probably been a huge
hassle to get the voice actress
kit harris back for the re-release of
the game just to record those few lines
it's still kind of jarring to listen to
since flood now tells you to press the
button over and over
use the button to press the button you
can then press the button
to enter a body of water and press the
button
but speaking of voice lines mario
actually has quite a few that were cut
from the games released back in 2002
and i mean actual lines not just random
yahoos or yippies
for longtime fans of the mario series or
nintendo games in general
you probably know that a pretty common
trend in nintendo games is for the
protagonists to not audibly speak
much or in some cases at all looking at
you
zelda this is the same when it comes to
mario but apparently the initial plan
was to have mario talk quite a bit more
in sunshine
here have a listen ciao another door
hello door primo cool too
cool perfecting it's fun feeling good
oh my head i imagine you'll be spending
a fair amount of time at the princess's
side
hmm look like a mario's gonna have to
find a job
that last line the one about mario
finding a job is quite funny since i'm
pretty sure the whole plumbing gig
is just a cover up he's clearly a
professional mustache grower
but the self-referential humor is only
present in the japanese version of the
game
even though it was recorded in english
definitely
doesn't make sense as to why it was
removed for the international versions
but who knows maybe the developers
figured mario shouldn't be heard talking
about getting a job because then
we would get jobs and stop playing mario
games as much
but enough about mario's voice lines
let's talk about removed objects and
models
there's an unused enemy called the
hinokiri which literally translates to
fire chestnut
hence its fiery chestnut-like appearance
this enemy can be seen in the space
world 2001 trailer for sunshine but was
cut
by the time the game actually released
though its files still can be found
there's also a removed nozzle for flood
that was never
actually modeled but had its mechanics
built into the empty game object that
was
apparently going to be a sniper nozzle
the sniper was going to be able to shoot
water at 100 times the power of the
regular nozzle
after a charge up period similar to the
rocket nozzle
which we're assuming is what the nozzle
evolved into
not that i was able to use any of those
for my sunshine challenge video
there are also some removed areas for
the game and a giant
cut mechanic that i have no clue how it
would have been used had it not gotten
cut from the final release
but let's start with the areas i'm sure
many of you are all too familiar with
the trend of placing a giant eel in a
super mario water level
and in sunshine not only do we have to
descend deep under the water triggering
everyone's thalassophobia into some
ancient submerged ruins but we do so
to fight a giant eel or rather to brush
its teeth lots of fans have
very very vivid memories of this boss
fight but there's actually a detail
regarding the eel that implies that
there may have been another mechanic to
this fight you see the eel's throat and
stomach
are not only modeled but fully textured
as well
meaning the eel was probably initially
meant to you know
swallow you whole for those of you who
have played the legend of zelda ocarina
of time
being swallowed by sea creatures is
apparently a trend with nintendo games
but enough about jonah and the giant eel
delving once again into the cut content
from sunshine there are several
references and commands and even camera
behaviors that allude to the inclusion
of
multiplayer in the game yeah multiplayer
and what's even more
crazy is it apparently wasn't going to
be the kind of multiplayer that we see
in odyssey
where another player can control the
gadget feature while the first player
controls mario as far as i can tell the
second player was actually going to
control
shadow mario this functionality was
probably scrapped early on since
trying to access it makes the camera
super glitchy but my guess
is that one player was supposed to be
mario hosing down the other player
playing as shadow mario which may have
actually been a pretty neat multiplayer
idea now that i'm thinking about it
but alas this and many other minor
features will never be experienced by
anyone through normal means and the
multiplayer is
too broken to ever experience without a
complete recreation from the ground up
while there are quite a few other random
pieces of cut content in easter eggs
here and there i feel like we covered
the vast majority of the most
interesting ones and we'll end it there
but i wanted to include a big shout out
to the website that provided me with
more than 90
of the information from this video
called the cutting room floor it's a
place run by some passionate gaming
enthusiasts who love
delving in and finding content like this
and i wanted to give credit where credit
is due
so if any of the website's staff happens
to catch this video here's a big thank
you from the bandit
and also a huge thanks to nbc for
helping out with this video
really gave it that special flavoring it
needed be sure to catch the big sunshine
challenge video live
right now over on his channel featuring
yours truly where i contributed a
hundred percent of my vocals but
zero percent of the skill if you enjoyed
this video i would greatly appreciate it
if you would consider dropping a like so
youtube
knows it's a good video and subscribing
to the channel to stick around for the
next one
also huge huge huge thanks to all of my
supporters who help make
every video come to life in ways you
can't even imagine
if you're interested in joining the
ranks of my elite and getting some
pretty awesome perks along the way click
that join button below or follow the
links in the description to find out how
also down there are links to my social
media pages so come hang out over there
that's all i've got for this one so as
always i hope you have a wonderful rest
of your day
this is madintina bandit signing out
[Music]
you